these seabirds are getting ready for a
great show and just maybe a quick bite
to eat
whoa how about that these are bottlenose
dolphins rampaging up on shores
scattering fish and causing a major
Hollywood
are they just showing off the dolphin
equivalent of hot rodding the Dolphins
maybe placer than most species and
smarter as well but like so many
behaviors it's all about staying
well-fed bottlenose dolphins are among
the most inventive and intelligent
hunters in the sea and while bottlenose
dolphins often hunt close to shore this
coordinated assault on the beach is a
sophisticated technique developed here
in the salt marshes of South Carolina
first a Dolphins Scout locates schools
of fish in the channel then the other
dolphins rush the shore creating a wave
that washes the school of fish on to the
shores then using their superior
above-water eyesight the Dolphins grab
the fish and consume them and after that
it's time to do it all over again until
the Dolphins get tired or the fish
supply runs out whichever comes first
the Dolphins clearly relished this kind
of hunting and the birds like it too
here's a fascinating bit of trivia
that'll wow your friends
the Dolphins always rush the shore
landing on their right side the teeth on
this side of their mouth get worn down
from chewing the mud and silt that
sloshes in with the fish the Dolphins
can be so exuberant they actually beats
themselves sometimes it seems they're
almost trying to crawl back on the same
land they left 50 million years ago when
their ancestors first moved into the sea